you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from 1999 between Gary Kasparov and
Veselin Topalov
a game that's now recognized as
Kasparov's immortal when you observe one
spectacular move right after the other
it's easy to know why this game has had
such a title attributed to it and why
many believe it to be the greatest chess
game ever played so we have Kasparov on
the white end opening up with E for to
Paula responding d6 d4 white build the
center soon enough we'll see black
strike added with either c5 or e5 d6
facilitates both Knight f6 Knight c3 and
black runs with a king side fiend cut
out in the meantime white forms this
nice battery looking to eventually trade
off dark square Bishop c6 black wants to
expand and on the Queen side f3 rules
out that Knight g4 move to secure that
dark square Bishop position b5 looking
for a timely Knight kick
that's avoided or it's ignored for right
now instead more development for white
connecting these Knights black doing
similar and now we have Bishop h6 so big
question for black at this moment what
do you do because if you Castle kingside
to defend the bishop you're setting
yourself up for something that's quite
reminiscent to the Sicilian dragon
Yugoslav attack where this H pawn comes
roaring right down here looking to
exchange off on g6 and then the H file
is peeled right open so we don't have
that instead it is Bishop takes Bishop
knowing now that not going to Castle
kingside there's not really a way to
dislodge that Queen and since she's
watching over f8 let's just can't go
king side now so instead black is going
to be running Queen side so steps are
taken in that direction with first
Bishop b7 and now first a3 for white
securing this position that Queen
Knights position on c3 c5 striking in
the center and producing a square for
that Queen
queenside castle for white queen east 7
king b1 a typical idea when you
queenside castle to scoot that king over
one square towards the corner square
oftentimes will be played in order to
just watch over a pond on a - it's not
the case here but rather more of a case
of just vacating c1 for this night
eventually we will see this guy take a
nice journey pivoting on b3 and
eventually hitting at that light square
bishop so eight six first reinforces b5
so that there's a later c5 move
available night c1 queenside castle
Knight b3 and now the tension in the
centers are resolved white recaptures
the pun presses forward since that b5
pawn is again supported this is
available the rook drops back and now
with that last move c5 this d6 pawn is a
little bit soft right here and one
reason for that is because the square
right in front of it is weakened with
that last pond move it's no longer
controlled by a pond and could become
vulnerable as a result but Black has
this covered with Knight b6 now we have
all three of blacks minor pieces in a
spot to get that advance in so g3 first
looking to get on maybe this diagonal
right here with check in similar to what
white did after queenside castle we have
black running towards the corner as well
Knight a5 black avoids that night for
Bishop exchange again this is an open
position and one that could become even
more opened so keeping those bishops on
is preferred bishop h3 development and
now here we go
d5 another break in the center is likely
to occur nothing is done about this
tension just yet instead we have the
Queen making use of the now open
diagonal giving a check the Kings side
steps that it's a little bit scary here
for the black King well maybe even a lot
scare because these pawns have pressed
forward black black is controlling a lot
of squares on the
whiteside but with all these pieces
still on the board and the queens in
particular this king has to be very
cautious
we don't have okay so we don't have
anything going on with these pawns just
yet instead getting the last piece
involved rook on h2 e1 opposite that
Queen and with this move there was a
great deal
well maybe even prior to that move maybe
even at this point with the Queen
dropping back to f4 first but there's
certainly a lot of calculation that
already went into this position right
here this rook on h2 e1 move I say that
because you need to now know how to
respond in a good way to d4 what do you
do about this pawn takes Knight runaway
a 2e to none of the above
it's Knight d5 offering and eventual
what looks to be an eventual epon after
there's a capture here and that's what
we have we have Knight takes Knight on B
takes e take sand now Queen d6 this pawn
is it seems like it's just going to be
dead but there's one of what I feel are
five really sharp moves that take place
starting right now in this move 24
they're not all in sequence but this
right here being the first shot rook
takes d4 if you okay you take the Queen
we just have the recapture white top of
palm and the rook is very active and
this King is still a little bit shaky
but black accepts the accepts the offer
takes the rook and basically says
showing and well now we have yet another
sharp move right here when we're not
having we're not having Queen takes Dean
because of just the Queen block and if
there's a rook check black could just be
interposing right here and with the
tension between the rooks there's no
time to really get that piece on d7 note
that if you take the Queen's here the
King recaptures if you take the knight
the King takes this whites whites doing
better again white has corrected me
black is doing better
white has invested a full rook so
avoiding Queen exchanges is very
important the key move here is rook a DS
rip to e7 excuse me what do you do in
this position you can't interpose on d7
with the night or rook because the Queen
there's tension between the Queen's
interposing on d7 interferes with the
Queen's protection if you go to b8 this
isn't good because of Queen d4 and now
with the threat of not only Queen a7
mate but also an indirect threat of
capturing this rook there's not a good
way to defend against Queen a7 if you
play the knight here there is there is
Bishop takes Knight and well if rook
takes Bishop we could have rip takes
Queen takes this and if the Queen's come
off white is this is a one end game
because of an eventual c4 take stakes
there's no time to take here because of
a fork and if this well the knight could
well you could actually play here this
is a one king upon King pawn endgame
with a couple minor pieces white being
up to pawns we don't have to have that
if the King plays here we could have the
Queen check sneaking over here as well
and she's ready to grab here etc it's
it's a win for white however you slice
it in short you just can't go to b8 from
this position after the rook gives a
check on e7 so what do you do you have
to press forward b6 hitting the night
Queen takes d4 right now and the King
grabs the knight White has invested a
lot of material a rook and a knight and
the King is now walking a tightrope b4
inching closer now towards the white
side Queen c3 threatens a million-one
there's only one good way to defend
against that and that is Queen takes d5
to defend against Queen b3 there's not
two ways to do that taking what the
bishop is not good enough of a defense
because of King b2 and it is still a
Queen b3 that is threatened for if let's
just say Queen takes rook
Queen b3 Bishop takes pawn takes what a
nice mate that would be so we're not
going to have that and it's very
important in other words to take with
the Queen to be in a spot to meet King
b2 width Queen D for the Queen's are off
the board black wins so we're not having
king b2 instead rook a7 couple different
mate threats right around the corner
Queen b3 or rook takes a six there's not
a good
there's not many ways you could be
defending against a six right here the
move chosen was Bishop b7 that is the
best move and keep in mind it is the
best because it takes both the rook and
the Queen to fend off the mate against
b3 or in other words these guys need to
be focused on the d4 square in order to
meet King b2 with Queen to d4 getting
the Queen's off the board if you play
rook d6 this right here is a case of a
rook being now overloaded having to
watch over a six as well as support and
eventual Queen d4 move after King b2 if
now Queen d4 you just take the Queen if
that then that it's me so in other words
after rook a7 its Bishop b7 giving up a
piece rip takes Bishop again there is no
Queen takes rook the Queen has to watch
out for that main so it just buys a
little bit of time now black for just
one moment doesn't have to worry about a
rook takes on a six Queen c4 offering a
queen exchange white needs to avoid this
grabbing this night and looking to now
get me on a6 just like the rook was
doing a move a couple moves back from a7
and now we have King a3 grabbing up on
Queen takes a king takes B and now a
really sharp important shot right here
c3 giving a check and well there's not
really a good solution at this point is
there because you take with the Queen
that runs into a mate and three Queen
takes the rook gives a check and then
after the Queen blocks the rook takes
the Queen and that's main the other
choices if King be three we could just
have check King takes pawn queen b2 and
well King here is now force the bishop
comes back to its home square the queen
is lost so instead what we have is just
after c3 the King grabs that pawn now
the Queen makes use of this a1 square to
give a check King D to Queen B to to
give a check and the King needs to stay
off of these two squares as otherwise
the rook gives a check and that just
leads to very bad things very quickly
for example King here we would just have
a rook check and if the Queen doesn't
block if the King just grabs the pond
that's actually going to be mate on g2
here so instead once the Queen plays to
be to its King d1 and now a really sharp
move as well this is I believe the the
fourth really spectacular move that
we're seeing in this game Bishop f1 what
is going on exactly okay most directly
the Queen is hit and now well there's
really not a good thing to do because if
you grab the bishop this is going to run
into Queen c2 King e1 and now the rook
gives a check there is only one move
after Queen takes Queen that's game over
so you can't take the bishop in short
and you can't really move the Queen to a
square where she serves two rolls and
right now she has to watch over this
Queen to see one move there's two things
being threatened potential for Queen c1
which is me or Queen to e2 and there's
not a square that this Queen can move to
where she watches over both c1 + e2 so
what black tries is rook d2 just
allowing for that Queen to be taken and
instead throwing a punch at that white
Queen but now we have the last really
sharp shot by white rook d7 just
depending the rook to the king and
there's still this threat right here
against the Queen it can't be taken
because of just the very direct Queen
rook and well what else do you do since
okay the rook is pinned you can't take
the Queen what's the solution here
there's not a way now in this position
for the Queen to move and defend this
rook successfully so what black now
tries is just grabbing the rook and
after Bishop takes Queen pawn takes
Queen takes rook we get to see in this
game many things the Queen for one makes
use of all three of these corners are
these three corner squares and well now
it's just the mopping up phase of the
game we saw a bunch of fantastic moves
already at least five of them and it
finishes up in the following way rook d3
trying to stay a little bit coordinated
Queen a8 c3 Queen a4 lands a check King
e1 f4 just avoids rook takes F the king
inches over rook d2 just trying to stay
connected and after Queen a7 Black has
to throw in the towel because what do
you do you have Queen takes H being
threatened and there's no time for black
to take on h2 to defend against that h7
pond because otherwise our because we
would have just Queen to g1 and the rook
would be dead and well what else is
there to do because if you just start
pushing these pawns the Queen goes and
threatens them she ends up getting one
of these guys and these guys start
rolling looking to get another Queen
there's no good solution for black
however you slice it so a really really
sharp game multiple really really nice
moves
and I really liked seeing that King go
for that little hike right here this is
a little journey that he ended up taking
and after it was all said and done the
black King ended up on the square that
that white King started out on so a
really interesting final position
without a doubt with a lot of again
spectacular moves so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of
take care bye